Hi, my name is Lorenzo.
I'll be your instructor in this
course as we explore the design and
implementation of web APIs.
Throughout this course, you'll work on
several mini projects that each focus on
a specific concept you'll learn.
At the end of this course,
you'll use all the skills learned to
create a final object called Meat and
Eat, a social application for meeting
people based on their food interests.
By building the back end of this
application you will gain some insight
into how these social applications
work underneath the hood.
In addition you will learn some tips
when it comes to designing API endpoints
for clientside consumption of your code.